hi i'm andrew morgan this is a talk on
polynomial identity testing the
evaluation of rational functions and
constitutes joint work with dieter van
milkepig
polynomial identity testing is the
computational problem where you're given
an arithmetic formula computing a
polynomial p and you have to decide
whether or not p is the zero polynomial
this has a simple randomized algorithm
you just evaluate p at a random point
however it's a major open problem to
construct a deterministic algorithm for
pit
general purpose deterministic algorithm
would be
called white box de-randomization where
it has full access to the formula
there's also black box de-randomization
where you consider only pseudorandom
evaluations and
plug them into the simple randomized
algorithm
so both forms of de-randomization
are related to circuit lower bounds in
boolean complexity theory
and this
uh
thus polynomial identity testing plays
the role of a morally complete problem
for de-randomization
in the sense that
de-randomizing it should give us a great
deal of insight into de-randomization
for general computation
on the other hand it also explains why
this de-randomizing this problem is so
hard
and in particular we may progress by
looking at some very restricted
classes of polynomials
so we're going to talk about black box
deranimization and in black box d
randomization the central object is the
generator
so in pit generators without osto
generality take the following form
there are fresh c variables
and then the substitutions are
polynomials in those c variables
and then what we want is that whenever p
is a nonzero polynomial making the
substitution of the generator into p has
a non-zero result as a composition of
polynomials
and we want to do this for polynomials
in some class c such as polynomials
computable by small formulas or small
circuits or other models of computation
black box deranimization
in terms of generators of this form
means you design a generator and you
want a very small c length
and then you test whether this
composition of p with g is zero by doing
now random evaluations of the seed
variables
and the point as long as is that as long
as your seed is short this is a lot less
randomness
in particular as long as your c is short
and the degree of all the polynomials
involved are reasonably small then you
can do a trivial derandomization of this
reduced randomness
algorithm
and
everything's good then only polynomial
many evaluations in fact can suffice
so we make progress on black box
de-randomization
by a couple conceptual contributions and
some technical ones
so our first conceptual contribution is
the use of rational functions in
generators
instead of just polynomial substitutions
the substitutions are rational functions
of the seed
specifically we introduce a new
generator the rational function
evaluation generator
and through studying it we demonstrate
that the use of rational functions as
substitutions
can improve understanding of the
generators that we have
and arguably lead to more elegant
constructions
we also take a systematic approach to
studying generators by looking at the
vanishing ideals
so the vanishing ideal of a generator is
the set of polynomials such that when
you plug in the generator you get the
zero polynomial
for any complexity class c
the generator works to deranimize pit
for c if and only if the vanishing ideal
and c have at most the zero polynomial
in common
so this is the importance of the
vanishing ideal
because it precisely captures the power
of g as a generator
particular deranimization
using a generator g is equivalent to
lower bounds for the vanishing ideal of
g
and
our overall goal with this is that by
looking at the vanishing ideal we can
focus research on the generator itself
which we have some control over
uh rather than the syntactic classes
where uh
it can be
challenging i guess to to study them say
the least
yeah
okay so we take this approach
and apply it to the rational function
evaluation generator
and our technical contributions are
based on this
so first of all uh we show a connection
between the rational function evaluation
generator and the widely used
shibuyakovocovis generator
specifically they have the exact same
vanishing ideal up to rescaling of the
variables the xi's
so what this means for de-randomization
is that if you have a class that's close
under variable rescaling such as just
about any syntactic class that people
consider
then sv works to de-randomize that class
if and only if rfe does
so this gives a really strong notion of
equivalence between these generators and
therefore results for one carry over
immediately to results for the other
so that's our first tactical
contribution
our next one concerns
looking more closely at the vanishing
ideal itself
and specifically we come up with a
generating set for the vanishing ideal
of rfe as well as sv
this generating set is small and
explicit
for
fixed settings of parameters it's
polynomial in size in terms of the
number of variables
and
it is explicit in the sense that each
generator is a very structured
determinant
and small determinant
in fact a taking an appropriate subset
of our generating set you get a grubner
basis um if you know what that means
as implications of having found this
generating set
we derive some tight bounds for certain
properties of the vanishing ideal
for either generator namely we find
their exact minimum degree the minimum
sparsity of a polynomial in the
vanishing ideal and if you know what
that multilinearity means
we find the minimum partition class size
for these that multilinearity structure
we also use the lower bounds
de-randomization equivalence in reverse
because sv is known to derandomize some
classes c
we can conclude that because our
generators are in the vanishing ideal
that they cannot be computed in such
classes c
so there's a variety of works where sv
is
the exclusive generator that's used and
in all such cases our generators are not
computable by the classes hit in those
works
so in addition to computing a generating
set we also compute or also provide a
membership test
for the vanishing ideal
for the specific case of multilinear
polynomials it can be expressed in terms
of partial derivatives and zero
substitutions and therefore inherits has
a somewhat combinatorial flavor to it
and that combinatorial flavor carries
over to
general polynomials but just gets a bit
more technical
implications of the membership test are
first of all
derivatives and zero substitutions are
complete for reasoning with rfe and sv
via this membership test so if you can
prove that
rfe or sv works to de-randomize p-a-t
for some polynomial p
then you can prove it by taking some
derivatives and zero substitutions of p
to demonstrate the utility of this kind
of completeness of reasoning
uh we show
uh an alternate proof for polynomial
time black box deranimization of pit for
read wants formulas
this result was originally due to
menahan and volkovic
and they one step of their proof is a
bit ad hoc
but we replace that step by something
with a much more explanatory power based
on our membership test
in addition to reproving known results
we make some new progress on
de-randomization for rewards oblivious
algebraic branching programs
robps which we'll define later
so that's my brief summary here's an
outline for the rest of the talk so
first i'm going to define sv and rfe
and then we'll talk about the
equivalence of the two
and we'll look at the generators for
their vanishing ideal
and then we'll take a look at this
membership test
and
with both of those we'll see some other
consequences
this buckovich generator
is defined in terms of some parameters
so
for each variable x i the generator
requires selecting a distinct
scalar from the ground field that we
call an abscissa
the abscissa for x i is just denoted ai
from here the generator sv1 can be
defined as taking in as c two variables
y and z
and then substitutes for x i
z times the i lagrange interpolating
polynomial as a function of y
so what this does is if you plug in say
a i for y
then x i gets z and the remaining
variables get zero
and that holds for all i
so you can view sv1 as interpolating
every point with
at most one non-zero coordinate and it
does so in a smooth
way
for
general positive integers l sbl can be
defined as the sum of l copies of sv1
each one getting a fresh seed
properties are
as sp1 contains the points of having
weight at most one
svl contains points with hamming weight
at most l
and more generally it has this property
known as l-y's independence and serves
as a analog to that in the algebraic
setting
the
rational function evaluation generator
is defined as follows
so it has parameters 2
and just like sv for every variable
there is a distinct abscissa
it also has parameters k and l that give
us bounds on the seed
and the generator for rfe kl takes a
seed a univariate rational function
where the
the numerator has degree at most k it's
a parameter and the denominator has
degree at most l the other parameter
the substitution performed by rfe is
just that x i gets the evaluation of the
seed f at the abscissa for x i
as an example for k equals 1 and l
equals 2
a typical seed would look like this
we have this universe this univariate
rational function in alpha c one alpha
plus c zero over d two alpha squared
plus d one alpha plus d zero
and the substitution for this
is uh x i gets the same expression but
with the abscissa for x i replacing
alpha
and the key point to note is that the
this rational function f
uh the numerator degree is again bounded
by k which was one and then by the
denominator degree was bounded by two
which is l
um and this notation r v k l uh we put k
over l to represent the degree bound on
the numerator over the denominator
so these generators s svd and rfe are
equivalent um i'll show that for the
case of sv1
which is very strongly equivalent to
rf01
so i'm going to start by writing down
the substitution for sv1
just reproduced from the previous slide
and then
the first step is we're going to just
get rid of this denominator that's on
the right and we're going to just absorb
that into the variable x i by rescaling
it
so we get a new substitution that looks
like this where x
is a rescaled version of x i
then we're going to rewrite this
as a product of two terms where the
first one does not depend on the index i
and the second one depends only on the
index i and not on the other indices
and then we're going to re-parametrize
the seed so this
under-braced segment is going to get
replaced by just a new variable z prime
and you can view this as just a change
of variables
the resulting substitution for x i tilde
is just z prime over y minus the
abscissa for x i
which is really just
the evaluation of a rational function at
the abscissa for
x i
um where the rational function has
degree 0 as a function of alpha in the
numerator and it's degree 1 into the
denominator
and if you think about it as z prime and
y vary you get every rational function
with these degree bounds it's the change
of variables and the rescaling of the
xi's these are both invertible so what
we conclude is that plugging sv1 in for
x for any polynomial p
gives you zero if and only if
plugging rfp01 into these three scaled
variables
x i tilde
gives you zero
so uh this is the sense in which these
vanishing ideals are equal sv1 and rv01
have the same vanishing ideal up to this
variable rescaling
and we just say that the generators are
equivalent
so sv and rv are equivalent more
generally
so for the case of general l
svl is
recall is the same as the sum of l
independent copies of sv by the previous
equivalence svl is equivalent to the sum
of l independent copies of r of e01
and the latter
if you have a sum of l rational
functions with degree zero over degree 1
then by giving them a common denominator
you get a single rational function of
degree l minus 1 over degree l
and
you can reverse this process using
partial fraction decomposition
and this establishes an equivalence
between a sum of l independent copies of
r v 0 1 and r l minus 1 l
and therefore svl is equivalent to rv l
minus 1 l
for deranimization
again this means is that for any class c
svl derandomizes c
if and only if uh rfe-l minus one l
works to de-randomize c
you can consider rfe with more general
parameters k and l
and by just increasing k or l as
appropriate
you can get to a set of parameters
that's equivalent to sv
by at most doubling
the length of the seat that's necessary
and so for the purposes of polynomial
time dear randomization
rfe and sv are uh strongly equivalent
so next up we're going to talk about
generators for the vanishing ideal
i'll start by constructing them and then
telling you how they generate
so let's fix a seed g over h for rfe kl
so the degree of g is most k the degree
of h is almost l
and we're going to write down this
expression that is linear in the
coefficients of h and g and expresses
the substitution
as an equation
so making explicit the coefficients of g
and h
we can collect this equation as i varies
into a system
so the system looks like this
and
the point is that by looking at the
system we can see that
if we plug in rfekl and for the xi's
with respect to the cg over h
then this matrix has a non-trivial
linear dependence of its columns
namely given by the coefficients of h
and g
so what this means is that if we look at
any full size square sub matrix
its determinant is going to vanish when
we plug in rv kl for any seed
meanwhile the determinant that you get
is without the substitution is non-zero
and so
this polynomial that's the determinant
without the substitution
must be a non-zero polynomial in the
vanishing ideal
so these polynomials are important
we'll give them the name elementary
vanderman circulation
and
they're formed by selecting distinct
rows
from the system our distinct variables i
one through i k plus l plus two and you
form this determinant out of it
so here's an example of evc01 with
indices one two three
uh it's this determinant right here i
expanded as some monomials it looks like
this
so we can see right away that this has
degree two uh it's a multi-linear
polynomial each variable appears to
degree at most one
and
every monomial that's consistent with
that description and x1 x2 and x3
appears with a non-zero coefficient in
this polynomial
so these properties hold in general uh
evc is homogeneous to degree l plus one
and it's multilinear
and every monomial that's consistent
with that description and the relevant
variables is present with a non-zero
coefficient
so the evcs do generate the vanishing
ideal of rfe this is a theorem
sketch of the proof
we're going to
first write down this ideal generated by
the evcs
and we're just going to compare it to
the vanishing ideal so because the evcs
belong to the vanishing ideal the ideal
they generate is a subset of the
vanishing ideal and so we just need to
show the other inclusion
we do this by doing a multivariate
polynomial division by the instances of
evc
applied to
any polynomial in the vanishing ideal
for rfekl
and the result is a structured remainder
term
and what we do is we show directly the
kl
when you plug it in to any non-zero
remainder with that structure then the
result is non-zero since our plugging
rvkl into
evc gives you zero this means that the
only way that plugging
rfe kl into a polynomial
um can have zero result is if the
remainder has zero result and that's
only if the remainder itself is zero so
that means that any polynomial in the
vanishing ideal when we do this division
has to have a zero remainder and
therefore belong to the evc ideal
just a brief note on what the structure
is
there's a set c of k plus one variables
and every monomial that's in the
structured remainder uses only variables
in c and most l other variables
okay so that's the generating set
we can derive
some consequences of this
so first of all we can derive some basic
properties of the vanishing ideal first
of all the minimum degree of any
non-zero polynomial is l plus one this
is witnessed by evc
the minimum sparsity is k plus l plus
two choose k plus one this again is
witnessed by edc
and then among set multi-linear
polynomials which are polynomials where
you partition the variables in two sets
and every monomial has to use exactly
one variable from each part of the
partition
we show that for every set multi-linear
polynomial of degree l plus one each of
these or can only be in the vanishing
ideal if moreover each of these
partitions has size at least k plus two
so this is not witnessed by evc but it's
witnessed by a related construction
that i won't give here
we also conclude
some lower bounds
using prior derandomization results that
use sv so ebc belonging to the vanishing
ideal cannot belong to any class that we
know sv works to de-randomize
since evc is really explicit this is a
nice lower bound
so
that's our generating set next i'm going
to move on to tell you about the
membership test
so let's fix p to be a multi-linear
polynomial i'll just tell you the test
for multi-linear polynomials
um the theorem states that
uh p belongs to the vanishing ideal if
and only if so it's a precise
characterization both of two conditions
hold
first is kind of a non-triviality
condition
first p can have no monomials that use
very few variables in most l nor almost
all variables in other words all
but k
so for polynomials that don't need that
restriction on the second condition
kicks in
and it says that p belongs to the
vanishing ideal only if
uh
for every way of choosing k zero
substitutions and l partial derivatives
such they're all on different variables
uh the resulting polynomial
when you apply those operations to p has
to vanish when you substitute uh
rfe with a particular seed that depends
on the sets k and l for your zero
substitutions and partial derivatives
so the substitution looks like this
so something i'll point out is that uh
in the special case where k and l are
constant so for example you're trying to
do polynomial time black boxes
randomization
the number of conditions
to check here is only polynomials
corporately quite small
we conclude from the statement that zero
substitutions and partial derivatives
are
complete for reasoning
with
reasoning about whether rfe or sv hits a
given polynomial
in particular we could suppose that
we know that rfekl works for some
multi-linear polynomial p
and perhaps it's through some very
difficult complex means
the membership test says that in fact
there has to be a structured way of
proving this
namely either p has a monomial with few
variables in it
or a monomial with all but few variables
or there are
k zero substitutions and l derivatives
so that when you apply those to p the
result is non-zero at this very specific
point
so as an example
we reprove uh the result of minahan and
volkovich that one copy of sv
works to de-randomize p-i-t for
read-wants formulas in a black box
fashion
uh the critical step is involves
considering the sum of two variable
disjoint polynomials
and whereas mv had a
somewhat ad hoc argument
you can think about it in terms of the
membership test where each of those
three bullets above
constitutes a an obstruction for p to
belong to the vanishing ideal
and when you have a sum of two variable
disjoint polynomials
any obstruction for either term in the
sum
is automatically inherited by the entire
sum and that explains
why if sv hits p1 or p2 then it hits the
sum
okay
so uh that's reedmon's formulas formulas
it's an old result
so next up i'm going to talk about
a newer result
which relates to reed wants oblivious
algebraic branching programs
so briefly they look like this
in the sense that they're a graph
each of these edges should have a
polynomial in it that's univariate in
the the variable that's written below
it could be each of these miss as
encoding what are
the
thing as a matrix of the polynomials on
the edges
between each layer
and then the polynomial computed by the
roavp
uh is uh formed by taking the sum over
all paths from the left to the right of
the product of the polynomials along
that path
so critically every variable appears in
exactly one layer and
are between every pair of layers
and between every pair of layers
there is at most one variable that
appears there
every variable appears exactly even once
so
another way to define this is just the
rovps are polynomials that are products
of matrices for each matrix
its entries are univariate polynomials
in the same variable and wherever each
variable appears and it was one at most
one matrix in the product
so an important parameter of roavps is
their width
in terms of the graphical picture it's
the largest number of nodes in any of
these gray boxes
in terms of the matrix representation
it's the largest dimension of a matrix
in the product row or column
constant with rodps are at the frontier
of research in pit
a lot of people have tried
and we have a lot of special cases and
some black box randomization that comes
very close
but they're
still out of reach
for us and we won't resolve that today
but we make some progress towards it
specifically uh we give a as a proof of
concept of this uh overall
approach we take towards through
studying the vanishing ideal
uh
what it can be the result we have can be
stated as a lower bound
where
every roabp that computes a non-zero
polynomial in the vanishing ideal for
sbl
if it moreover has degree l plus one
then you get a lower bound on the width
of that rodp that grows with l
so this lemma
lower bound applies to evc l minus 1l
and others
any degree l plus 1 polynomial in the
vanishing ideal
and it extends to uh any polynomial with
a non-zero degree alpha one homogeneous
part
as well
so in terms of do randomization what
this theorem looks like
is that svl works to de-randomize pit
for roavps of with less than this bound
that contain
a monomial with the appropriate degree
so
stated this way i think one of the
reviewers called this strange which i
don't necessarily disagree with but if
you view it in terms of the lower bound
um it's kind of clearly handling a
special case of uh
proving lower bounds for the entire
vanishing ideal and it's a natural
starting point namely the least degree
for which the vanishing ideal is
non-trivial
so in particular if you could generalize
this lower bound to every degree then
you would have a full de-randomization
full black box deranimization for
constant with robps
so that's our progress there
along the way uh we needed most of our
results rely on a particular technical
lemma that we call the zoom lemma
i'll show it to you for multilinear
polynomials
so
the idea is that we can
we need a technical lemma that lets us
show when plugging k l into p as
non-zero
and the way this lemma works is you
prove it by zooming in on a subset of
the monomials in p
so for a multi-linear polynomial you
select these well generally select these
disjoint sets k and l
and then for multi-linear polynomials
you look at uh
taking derivatives with respect to the
variables in l and zero substitutions
with respect to the variables in k
so this has the effect of throwing out
any monomial in p that either depends on
a variable in k or does not depend on a
variable in l so it's
got this combinatorial flavor of zooming
in on a subset of the monomials
dilemma states that if this zoomed in
polynomial does not vanish at a
particular substitution that looks like
a substitution of rfe with the same
familiar seed of fkl if we saw the
membership test
then we can conclude that rfe kl work if
you plug that into p you get a non-zero
result where k is the number of zero
substitutions and l is the number of
derivatives
so as a brief sketch of the proof
the idea is that instead of
parameterizing rfe
by the coefficients of the numerator and
denominator we parameterize it in terms
of the seeds roots and poles
and then we do
we plug rv into p
and then we do a laurent series
expansion
near the roots and poles of this
specific seed fkl
the point is that
through some degree considerations and
thinking in terms of the multiplicity of
the roots and poles
and what this means in terms of laurent
series
we can focus on a particular
coefficient of the rod series and it
turns out that that coefficient is
non-zero
as long as this evaluation of p-hat is
non-zero
coefficient is proportional to p-hat
evaluation at this point
so
that's more or less the proof it gets a
bit technical
once you try to actually spell it out
but that's the high level idea
so that's our zoom lemma
the last thing i want to tell you is
something that
doesn't formally appear in our results
but is still a conceptual perspective
that was very helpful for us in
developing these results initially and
it uses the language of alternating
algebra
so i'm going to present it for you in
the very special case of k equals 0 and
l equals 1 and for degree 2 polynomials
in fact multi-linear polynomials
because this lets me phrase everything
in terms of network flow
and then alternating algebra is just the
language that you need to generalize
this to higher parameters
so evc you recall
ubc stands for the elementary
vandermonde circulation
um so we'll see
this connection with network flow is
actually where the name comes from so
we're going to start by looking at evc
01
and when you expand it out as monomials
it looks like this
the idea of the representation is that
this is not very helpful as a way of
looking at this polynomial you want
something that's more helpful
so we're going to take the step of
representing it graphically so we're
going to make a graph where every
variable gets a vertex and between any
pair of vertices we're gonna have an
edge representing the monomial that's
the product of those variables
and then for every coefficient of a
monomial we'll just put that on each
edge corresponding edge as a weight
so it gives us this picture for evc
and
something that's worth pointing out is
that any multilinear degree 2 polynomial
can be represented in this way
so all we're doing is taking the
coefficients and normalizing them
so the next step is we're going to
try to eliminate some of the
apparent complexity that's not necessary
here namely if you look at
this weight on the edge between i1 and
i2 it's this determinant
and this determinant actually doesn't
depend on i3 in any way
so it's going to be the same weight for
any instance of evc as long as it uses
i1 and i2
so the idea is just to normalize that
out
and when you do uh you get a picture
that looks like this
so i've drawn arrows in here to
represent that these edges become
oriented and this reflects the fact that
the determinant has a an orientation to
it in the sense that the order of i1 and
i2
affects the sign of the determinant and
reversing the order of i1 and i2 on the
determinant causes a negative sign
so i'm capturing the order of i1 and i2
and the determinant by the direction of
the edge in this visualization
i could just as easily
make my rule go the other way
and what happens is the edges turn
around but also the coefficients pick up
a negative sign
and the point is that
even though these look like different
ways of putting ink on a page
they represent the same underlying
object
and this connection with network flow is
realizing
that the object they represent is this
simple unit of flow around a three cycle
so we reproduce a few different ways of
choosing these orientations but all
representing the same
three cycle of flow
so
three cycles of flow are interesting
because you can't like break them down
into smaller units of flow so we can
call them elementary circulations
so evc is a rule that
says you give it three vertices and it
gives you this elementary circulation in
this representation
meanwhile if you close uh the evc's
under linear combinations then you get
the degree two part of the vanishing
ideals this because the evc is generate
the vanishing ideal
meanwhile elementary circulations
generate all circulations under linear
combinations so what this means is that
the degree two part of the vanishing
ideal is
in this representation the same thing as
the polynomials that can be represented
as circulations
so you know i find this conceptually
appealing so hopefully you do too
uh
there's also um
this equivalent or this understanding of
circulations as
these kind of flow-like objects that
satisfy conservation so every vertex the
flow in equals the flow out
and
you can apply this characterization to
this understanding of evc
and vanishing ideal
and it turns out that our membership
test is just a way of restating
conservation of flow
in this representation
so as i said before
this is the specific case of k equals
zero l equals one and degree two um in
order to generalize it to higher kl and
degree uh you want a higher dimensional
version of network flow and the language
for that and that's what alternating
algebra more or less provides
okay so that's all i have to say about
that except i'm going to give you an
example
so
let's consider this polynomial if you
look at it it's not clear whether or not
it belongs to the vanishing ideal but if
we convert it into this representation
you'll see that it forms a simple five
cycle
and therefore should belong to the
vanishing ideal
indeed if we take this five cycle and
break it up as a sum of three cycles
you know the cancellation on these edges
that are common to the two three cycles
or common to two three cycles
then
that tells us how to write p as a sum of
evcs
particular uh there's three cycle one
two three another one one three four and
another one uh one four five and that
gives us uh tells us what ubc's to
create and then adding them up
it gives us peak
so that's this understanding of the
vanishing ideal that we found very
helpful
hope you do too
so in summary
we
took a look at a particular generator
the rational function evaluation
generator and
through studying it kind of demonstrated
the utility of rational function
substitutions as generators instead of
just polynomial substitutions
we also demonstrated the systematic
approach toward de-randomization by
looking at the vanishing ideal
and in particular approved some results
for rodps
on the technical front
we proved that rfe is equivalent in a
very strong sense to sv
and we provided a generating set for the
vanishing ideal of rfe nsv
particularly also partner basis
we also provided a membership test for
the vanishing ideal
and both of these last two we saw
applications to de-randomization and
lower bounce
but with that
that's everything i have so thank you so
much for watching